let's talk about the best trick or or
way or method of finding out if someone
is cheating on their diet now there's a
lot of weight loss programs out there
that have cheat days built into the
program and I think that's a mistake
because it's going to severely affect
the results because once you start it's
really hard to stop that being said I
was the worst of the worst okay as far
as cheating on my diet it took me years
before I started to be consistent and
have discipline now I have very good
discipline but in the past it was
terrible I would sort of do it go off go
on go on until I basically really hit
bottom I think it's good sometimes to
experiment to go off the program just to
see how your body responds so you
finally hopefully sooner than later can
be convinced that being on the program
is the best thing I just like how I feel
when I'm on the program consistently
versus off the program now when I have
my clinic there's a had a lot of people
coming in that would would cheat on the
program they would initially come in
saying well the program's not working
I'm not getting results so I had to kind
of pull out of them
you know maybe potentially cheating on
the diet but without making him feel
guilty or bad about it so I would very
gently ask them
is there anything that you're eating
that maybe you shouldn't be eating and
initially they would just say no I'm on
the program exactly well I did have a
little bit of potato chips but they're
organic or I did have some wine but it
was only a little bit I remember there
was a Whole Foods uh right next to my
office for a period of years and I would
shop in there a lot and one time I was
at the salad bar and I was looking
through the glass at a
patient um in the bakery section and I'm
just watching her she kept going past
these free samples these free brownie
samples
until finally she was looking to the
left looking to the right and grabbed
one and ate one and then we happened to
connect our eyes connected and she
quickly her face turned red she turned
around and started bolting
in a different direction so I had to run
after her and say listen it's totally
okay don't worry about it I think uh the
goal is to create enough Health in your
body
be out of the danger zone to the point
where you can go off the program when
you want to temporarily and go right
back on because you have control over it
I think that would be the goal but
there's a really good scientific way to
know if someone has gone off the program
and by going off the program on talking
about eating carbs and sugar testing
your blood sugars is not the best way
because it only tells you what's
happened the day before or the day of
but checking the A1C can give you an
average of three months of ingestion of
carbohydrate or the absence of eating
carbohydrates
what does A1C it's a test that measures
how much glucose is stuck to the protein
in your blood and so the more sugar that
you have in your body the higher
percentage of your hemoglobin is
affected or exposed to glucose so we
really want this A1c
percentage to be below
5.7 because if it's even like 4.4 your
blood sugars are like roughly around 79
or 80 which is really good but if your
A1C is like 4.0 your blood glucose
levels are running around 65. now you
might say that well that's hypoglycemia
abnormal well when you cut out sugar
from the diet your blood sugar levels
will start going down and down and down
in the 60s and that's normal because you
don't feel bad from that but the bottom
line is you want your A1c to be below at
least 5.7 when they start getting above
5.7 you go into what's called a
pre-diabetic range or your blood sugar
is oscillate between like 117 and up to
like 124 137 and then when the blood
sugars get like in the 140s your A1C is
going to be around 6.5 that's diabetes
and I've seen people have A1C like 11.
so it can go really high and the higher
it goes the more complications you have
from diabetes and I'm talking about the
the four big ones are complications to
your eye
complications to the inside of the
arteries around the heart complications
to your kidneys and complications to
your brain and nerves okay at the bottom
of your feet become a problem like numb
pain burning things like that and then
you start getting uh what is that um
memory problems dementia and the other
thing to know is that if you're anemic
or you're on certain medications or you
have other body problems like organ
problems kidney liver that can make your
A1c
higher than it is despite not eating
sugar so it can alter the results the
other thing to know is that if you're a
diabetic okay it's initially harder to
bring this A1C in blood glucose level
down to normal why because the pancreas
has been working really really hard and
chances are you only have like 50
percent of the cells that make insulin
look at the beta cells and so if you
can't make enough insulin on top of
having insulin resistance which is
basically a deficiency of insulin in the
cells you don't have that full magnitude
of that push down blood sugar effect
from insulin so the glucose level kind
of stays a little bit High because of
that on top of that your liver is making
a lot of new sugar and that's what
happens in diabetes
it's one of the reasons why the blood
sugar level is so high if you're not
eating sugar because the body is making
sugar and you'll see it higher in the
morning and it's called a dawn phenomena
and that's because of this thing called
gluconeogenesis the production of new
sugar so just realize that if you're
diabetic and it's not coming down to
normal right away just give it more time
keep working on it it's just going to
take some time it could take weeks
months
usually not a year but I'm going to show
you at the end of this video how to
speed things up that being said one of
the best indicators to know if if the
program is working if you're in ketosis
by lowering your carbs if you're not
cheating and you're keeping your blood
sugars really level for a longer period
of time loss of appetite basically means
you're burning fat is the best like
indicator to know that you're doing the
right things if someone were to come
into my office when I was in I practiced
and say it's not working and I have
cravings and I'm still hungry then I
know their sugar levels are too high so
I don't even need to do the A1C but a
common confusion I think with a lot of
people is this all it takes is a little
bit of carb
okay or sugar to bump you out of ketosis
for a good amount of time for a couple
days two or even three days and I'm
talking about even a half a glass of
wine or a couple pieces of bread now why
is that
because you don't just go out of ketosis
and go back in real fast it's easy to go
out of ketosis but it takes especially
in the beginning
period of two days or longer to get into
ketosis
so
this cheat day
kind of really knocks you out of the
program
for a good amount of time
so you can imagine if someone's cheating
every other day or every third day
the progress they're going to make not
that great especially if someone is a
diabetic or pre-diabetic or has bad
insulin resistance
and they're having a hard time losing
weight which is the great majority of
the population if someone is a diabetic
they should also know
this is important if they're struggling
keeping this blood sugars down having a
lower A1C lower blood glucose and coming
off carbs and sugar
they should also at the same time
consume a good amount of nutrient-dense
foods
foods with phytonutrients
um supplements that come from natural
sources like a natural B1 or natural
sources of vitamin C things like a
turmeric nutrient dense vegetables the
phytonutrients in these Foods all can
help reduce the complications of
diabetes so even now their blood glucose
is high they can at least protect
themselves against all the side effects
of diabetes and hopefully over time use
less of the medication which sometimes
has more side effects than the actual
disease itself and also a blood glucose
test
measures the effect of glucose on the
blood okay most sugars like table sugar
honey even high fructose corn syrup
has about a 50 50 split between 50
glucose and 50
fructose and just a small amount of that
fructose affects your blood sugars
it destroys the liver and it acts like
alcohol
but as far as your blood sugars it won't
increase it very much it's the glucose
in that table sugar so I just wanted to
point that out because certain sugars
have more fructose than others of course
high fructose corn syrup is kind of a
synthetic processed type of sugar
without all the phytonutrients it's the
most deadly but there is one more sugar
that's even more deadly than that and
that would be this agave syrup which is
a refined product because it has 85
percent of it is fructose and that's
going to go right to the liver it's not
going to affect your blood sugars too
much but it's going to grow to your
liver and really uh create a fatty liver
and the liver deals with fructose the
same as alcohol now when someone comes
off sugar completely okay and they're
not eating hardly any carbs at all why
is it that your blood sugars will always
be a certain level why don't they just
come down to zero well you need certain
sugar for certain functions any of that
Sugar can be easily made by the liver
okay from other sources it doesn't have
to come from the body so your body will
always have a certain amount of sugar in
the blood the problem is realizing that
the average person consumes way way way
too much sugar in fact if we take a look
at normal sugar which is roughly about
80 milligrams per deciliter that's like
one teaspoon of sugar which is like four
grams of sugar and all of your blood at
one time so if you don't have any sugar
your body makes it if you have too much
and you test your sugar and it's normal
what that means is the background is
insulin is working really hard to yank
that Sugar out and putting in its
storage it can actually it's raising
your bad cholesterol it's making your
liver fatty so testing your blood
glucose doesn't really tell you anything
about what's happening with insulin too
much okay at least initially and it also
doesn't tell you about those cheat days
in the weekend because if you do really
good during the weekday and then you go
off on the weekends and you only test in
the weekday you're not going to see the
whole picture one point I want to make
about hypoglycemia low blood sugar when
you think about low blood sugar you
might think it could be caused by not
eating sugar
no it's caused by eating sugar because
what control sugar is insulin and
insulin is too high and it's pushing
your blood sugars down in summary number
one start consuming a good amount of
phytonutrients or nutrient dense foods
from your existing diet we call that the
healthy version of the ketogenic diet to
decrease the complications of these
blood sugars okay number two apple cider
vinegar is really good to take in water
diluted through the day to speed up the
process of correcting this insulin
resistance another really good remedy
would be berberine it's equivalent to
like taking metformin but without the
side effects so start to be more strict
if you want to go off the program go
right ahead just use it as an experiment
to see how you feel and hopefully you
won't take as long as I did to
eventually have discipline but give it
time to work because it will happen now
if you haven't seen my very popular
video
on blood sugars
that has gotten millions of views you
should check that one out I put it up
right here